Komputer kuantum bertujuan menyelesaikan masalah yang tak dapat ditangani
oleh komputer klasik — perkara-perkara
seperti mencari bahan yang sesuai untuk membolehkan
penangkapan karbon, untuk benar-benar
memerangi perubahan iklim, mengatasi masalah
baja yang lebih cekap yang boleh
mengelak kerosakan bumi tapi pada masa yang sama teruskan
rantaian bekalan makanan yang kita perlukan untuk memberi makan dunia
juga ada soalan asas tentang bagaimana alam semesta kita
disatukan dan bagaimana jirim bertingkah laku di peringkat atom
dan subatom yang perlu kita ketahui
ini adalah sempadan seterusnya
jom tengok satu kawasan penyelidikan yang dah pun bermula
pencarian bateri baru
bateri dah mengubah hidup kita dengan membolehkan kita bawa
komputer dan telefon pintar
tapi masih banyak lagi yang boleh dibuat — bateri sangat penting
untuk masa depan tenaga bersih kita
sama ada untuk menjanakan kereta elektrik, memang
menggalakkan tenaga boleh diperbaharui
kita perlukan kimia yang betul-betul berbeza
untuk mencipta bateri
masa depan — pengkomputeran kuantum
akan membolehkan kita melihat secara efektif ke dalam bateri
semasa tindak balas yang sangat kompleks berlaku, untuk membolehkan kita
memikirkan bahan-bahan baru
dan struktur bateri yang akan diperlukan
untuk menjanakan peranti generasi seterusnya
macam mana nak sampai ke sana? dengan membina peranti kuantum paling canggih di dunia
dan platform pembangunan
dan menjadikannya tersedia untuk dunia
hanya dengan bekerja sama sekarang
kita akan dapat menyelesaikan masalah yang akan kita hadapi
bersama-sama pada masa depan.